hello welcome to this video playing
Yardbird eric laurent here what do i do
against this and ok let's play c5 and
see what he is playing yeah closed
English not the most dangerous line but
lost the last two games and down it's
not the ideal opponent after having lost
two games especially if those games were
so idiotic so Bishop d3 what's the deal
show me
yeah so Knight f6 probably and just
develop now I can take play Queen a
phone if i take night Teague's that
could be compensation this is really one
of the things I hate most and shares
there are people blundering stuff and
then they get compensation out of
nowhere anyway so let's see i have moved
to Bishop [ __ ] so out of nowhere is a
bit strong but still so probably you
will take on c5 Queen a form also very
much possible
yeah okay there there are d55 moves here
595 doesn't work okay let's let's do
that salt song not an easy solution but
at least I get developed
okay so this isn't that bad I don't
think so so maybe this 495 so 95 okay I
Scott Queenie to check okay I'm taking
this so what now if I take on c3 and 25
this is at least speeding up everything
but the long diagonal is really really
bad
sorry you like this taking c5 and
putting this in a pin really strange
that you give up the game of the
exchange he wants to check me and then a
discovery if he most of the night now I
have queen dee 5 threatening queen age 1
so this looks ok
yeah I should also get some pressure on
the default him
it's pretty bad for white but I'm able
to screw up all kinds of positions so
let's seem
we place nothing move I probably have I
can probably try to double the rooks on
the diva
it's not easy to see a movie ack like 94
25 always white resins and it's no fun
with him I just do this and like this I
cannot paint here right in I can double
up on the diva I was of course an
extremely bad game from both sides first
he blundered the pawn I mean nobody does
that on purpose if somebody thinks that
so i blundered the pawn and with deform
yeah Queen a for you gets compensation
for this somehow maybe we should be six
in this this I was thinking that this
should be good but I can cancel I mean
these are this operation for white to
get the porn back it costs time this is
not to be underestimated b3 is good here
pointed out by the engine I don't have a
good square I have to play something
funky like this this is the computer
line with advantage to white of course
and so that was a huge hole yeah i'm not
sure if he had to take on c6 and this
was also kind of strange it's still a
queen g2 why not check young so my balls
are probably weird game from
and some in some regard ok I hope you
still enjoyed this little blunder fest
thanks for watching